some people
say that uh you know
i've read that comedy is about timing
well first of all do you agree and
second of all
no i'm serious it's not just that you're
saying yes
it's funny okay isn't it comedy is
tragedy plus timing is not that
is not the full reference what is it the
interrupting call knock knock joke
i'm not gonna do it but uh that's not a
timing thing
it's more of a repetition and then the
twist ending
you know the move oh the move yeah yeah
yeah yeah interrupting cow
you think of the banana the banana one
anyway
uh i'm not i'm not going there
yet you're talking to me
are you small wonder do you stand
sleeping in a wardrobe
yeah uh that's so british
but yet you're very i want to stay in a
closet because that is connotations
let's let's both come out of the closet
for a second
i love it let's talk about you relax
i wasn't saying i love you alex i was
saying i love you lex
oh you were talking to me yes that's
through the screen
so when you so you think about me when
you're with a with another man
i watch you when you're sleeping okay so
you're a dangle song you're really
active on twitter
yeah uh and somebody else asked on your
uh overly expensive membership
site uh what like
[Laughter]
how do you find uh humor different
in writing on twitter versus spoken
humor so
if that's a great question if humor is
about timing
how do you capture the timing and the
brilliance of the
whatever is underlying humor in the
context of twitter like
another way to say it is uh how do you
be
funny and yet thoughtful
on twitter so
with twitter you have to be the first
one to the punchline so when ron paul
had a stroke i was immediately being
like he's still the most articulate
libertarian
he's doing a great job by an impression
right now all the libertarians got ass
mad that's
and people like too soon or like when
someone dies you're making the jokes
about them it's like
when do you want to make the jokes about
someone just died a week later it
doesn't make any sense now you might too
soon it's perfect timing or you could
say
it's not appropriate ever but too soon
does not make sense in this
context um so that is something that i
enjoy doing it's also fun ruffling
people's
feathers if it's something i enjoy doing
i think
uh spoken versus writing is very
different because
when you are having good banter with
someone
for me as the audience knowing that it
is
on the spot really adds an element of
humor because then it's like wow this is
fun it's like a ping pong
match or something whereas in writing
it's
you're losing the tone you're losing the
relationship of a dynamic conversation
um and a lot of times the joke is just
giving a different type of joke
well it's funny but twitter there's a
sense especially your twitter
that you're you just thought of that
and you just wrote it yes like there's
is there's a feeling like
it's literally you talking as opposed to
what i imagine is there's some editing
or it doesn't look like it
whoever your editor is should be fired
[Laughter]
there's an interesting effect actually
if i want to say something
i don't know about uh
the something that's bothering me about
the presidential election or something
like that
like what are what is the actual central
idea that i'm trying to convey to myself
like you say i was having
hypothetical conversation with myself
okay
why am i putting my pants back on i'm
more comfortable this way
promo called malice20 sheath
underwear.com
okay
um that's she's uh
what is it what's the website she's
underwear.com sheath underwear.com
promo code malice20 and i forgot why is
that underwear
really nice because it has a dual pouch
technology to keep your man parts
separate they've also got women's stuff
but i don't know how that works yeah
there's the thing worth going somewhere
and the material is really refreshing i
mean it's really again and it makes your
ass look good
that's promo code mouse 20.
and it's made by it's made by a former
vet because he was in iraq so that's why
i like promoting it
yeah but when i'm writing the the the
tweet i
i like to it forces me to think deeply
about
the core of the message okay but what i
found this
really interesting effect like i don't
really do much editing on the tweet like
i'll just like think
and then i'll write it and then when i
post it like submit like i immediately
see the tweet very differently than it
was in my mind
huh i often delete like i delete i don't
know some percentage of tweets
about like two five seconds after
wow i don't know it's something well
once you send it
it's why the gmail send features uh undo
send features really nice
it's like it just changes the way i see
the thing so
it's very interesting it's uh but i
really love it that you can delete it
because
when i say stuff out in the wild like to
other humans
like others spoken spoken word
is like you can't delete what you just
said and i often regret the things i say
like in in on the spot like i shouldn't
have said that
really yeah i don't have that
well again whoever your editor is
what is it uh uh edith piatt
uh generic hand wow your french is as
bad as your english um
i don't have any tweets i regret because
if i sent a tweet that i regretted i
would
make amends i would make it a point if i
was a
needlessly offensive to somebody or
hurtful
or accidentally i would make sure to fix
it
and and go out of my way to make sure
that person feels
vindicated and validated by accepting my
apology that has never
happened had to happen thankfully i'm
also
someone who is not big on
taking the bait uh uh you know some
recently some people have come after me
pretty hard
and my perspective is that it's not
really about me
it's either i represent something to
them i'm just some
jackass with a twitter so if you're
getting this riled up over me
it's not really about me maybe i'm
delusional that's how i look at it so if
they are trying to provoke me into this
kind of heated exchange i will never
do it uh because that's not i'm not
interested in it and it's i don't think
there's gonna be any it's
like janet rankin you you can't win
it's just going to be like trying to win
a hurricane there's no
hero here
you